combien de kilomètres parcourus pour
assembler un jet privé signé bombardier
inaccessible pour la plupart bureaux
volants pour certains jouets pour
d'autres un avion est un véritable
mécano cet appareil est destiné au
canada son fuselage central se trouve au
japon sa partie avant et les nacelles
des moteurs sont conçus en irlande du
nord il fuselage arrière ainsi que
l'empennage oil jour où soleil du
mexique le cockpit est créé l usine de
montréal pour voler il vaut des ailes
toronto les fournit les moteurs il y en
a deux et sept en allemagne qu on les
assemble pour revenir sur terre un train
d'atterrissage est conçu à ajax en
ontario une fois tous ces morceaux
fabriquer ils partent vers toronto lieu
d'assemblage finale de l'appareil il
reste à mettre la dernière touche à cet
avion peinture mobilier appareils
multimédias seront choisis à montréal
lui livraison d'une aide privée à son
propriétaire une opération d'assemblage
qui aura fait le tour du monde